we're also making more efficient use of
hotels
by asking people to share rooms where
it's appropriate to do so we found an
additional 11 and a half thousand places
which will save taxpayers an extra 250
million pounds a year
and I say to those migrants who are
objecting this is more than fair
if you're coming here illegally claiming
Sanctuary from Death torture or
persecution
then you should be willing to share a
taxpayer-funded hotel room in central
London
to reduce pressures on local communities
we'll also House people on ships
the first will arrive in Portland in the
next Fortnight and we've secured another
two today that will accommodate another
thousand